[Musik]
punktsieg auf dem parteitag die frage
wer kanzlerkandidat der cdu werden soll
bleibt in der hand der parteichefin
rückholaktion mit folgenden deutschland
muss eine anhängerin und ihre kinder aus
einem gefangenenlager in syrien zurück
bringen
gelungener start in die weltcup-saison
die deutschen doppelsitzer im rodeln
dominieren den auftakt in innsbruck
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nacht hinein heute
um 7 geben sie uns 20 minuten an diesem
nachrichten samstag für den überblick
den sportlichen teil hat norbert lehmann
im blick mit wintersport und
fußballschuhe bekannter von mir
wer wird kanzlerkandidat oder kandidatin
der cdu
die antwort auf diese frage bleibt
zunächst mal sache der partei
vorsitzende annegret kramp karrenbauer
geht damit gestärkt aus dem
cdu-parteitag hervor in leipzig am
letzten tag gab es dort folgende
entscheidungen
es wird also keine urwahl geben der
antrag dass alle parteimitglieder über
die kanzlerkandidatur abstimmen sollen
wurde abgelehnt außerdem soll es keinen
ausschluss von huawei geben der
umstrittene chinesische konzern kann
prinzipiell am deutschen 5g netz mit
bauen
der bundestag soll aber hohe
sicherheitsstandards vorgeben und es
bleibt beim grund renten kompromiss mit
der spd die cdu pocht aber darauf dass
die vereinbarten bedingungen wirklich
eingehalten werden details zum letzten
tag in leipzig von mathis feldhoff
es gibt eine neue hackordnung in der
union die eine gehört bald zur
vergangenheit die andere kämpft um ihre
position und markus söder ist plötzlich
der strahlende held in der geschichte
sein auftritt bei der schwesterpartei
wird umjubelt auch weil der csu-chef
sich viel stärker als die cdu
vorsitzende vom politischen gegner ab
ich sage euch eine ist natürlich haben
die grünen moral
ich glaube die haben zum teil auch mehr
moral als wir die haben nämlich eine
doppelmoral und das sollten wir den
menschen unserem land endlich sagen
liebe freunde haben es verdient zu hören
die grünen sind der kommende gegner für
söder wie afd
sogar der feind die afc ist nicht
irgendwie eine konservativere union
sondern sie ist die eigentliche neue
ware npd und mit solchen leuten macht
man nicht sondern bekämpft sie und zwar
engagiert und streitbar liebe freunde
hat er sich damit in die reihe der
möglichen kandidaten für das kanzleramt
ein rein will west brüder offen aber den
weg dahin bestimmt er mit mit seiner
absage an eine urban
es wird eine kurze aber heftige debatte
auch weil die urwahl frage immer als
attacke auf die parteivorsitzende kind
an dieser stelle auch ein klares votum
dafür dass man diesen mitgliedern an der
basis eine starke stimme gibt
entscheidungen aus dem hinterzimmer die
im elfenbeinturm einsamen getroffen
werden sind nicht mehr zeitgemäß aus
unserer sicht von daher sage ich keine
angst vor den eigenen mitgliedern der
generalsekretär heldt massiv dagegen die
menschen wollen antworten auf ihre
fragen und nicht auf unsere frage am
ende sind es klare 80 prozent gegen ein
uhr war die cdu stärkt heute ihrer
vorsitzenden den rücken aber die
entscheidung wer die parteien die
nächste wahl führt ist nur verschoben
noch eine nachricht aus der politik der
alte und neue juso-chef heißt kevin
kühnert auf dem bundeskongress in
schwerin bestätigte die spd jugend den
30 jährigen in seinem amt kühnert bekam
knapp 89 prozent der stimmen das beste
ergebnis eines juso-chef seit 50 jahre
er hatte keinen gegenkandidaten
beim spd parteitag in zwei wochen will
kühnert auch für einen posten im
vorstand kandidieren
das ging jetzt sehr schnell der
libanesische clan chef ibrahim miri ist
aus deutschland abgeschoben worden und
seit heute vormittag zurück in beirut
der mehrfach vorbestrafte miri war im
juli schon mal in seiner heimat
abgeschoben worden
ende oktober tauchte er dann wieder in
bremen auf trotz einreisesperre und
beantragte asyl
das wurde abgelehnt innenminister horst
seehofer dankte den beteiligten stellen
dass die abschiebung so schnell möglich
gewesen sei mehr als 80 deutsche die
sich der terror miliz s angeschlossen
hatten sitzen in syrien in lagern fest
bisher wurden nur einige ihrer kinder
ohne eltern zurück nach deutschland
geholt
so geht s nicht entschieden zwei
gerichte deshalb muss heute zum ersten
mal auch eine erwachsene zurückgeholt
werden eine 30-jährige mutter mit ihren
kindern jürgen kehl und andreas
christian hat mit den einzuhalten
nordsyrien gefangenenlager für anhänger
der terror miliz es die zustände prekär
auch für mehrere dutzend deutsche unter
ihnen laura h aus mittelhessen
sie hatte sich salafisten angeschlossen
und war mit zwei kleinen kindern in das
kriegsgebiet gereist dort bekamen sie
ein weiteres kind ihr mann eines kämpfer
kommt ums leben
sie wird nun die erste e s anhängerin
die von deutschland zurückgeholt wird in
berlin keine details nur eine karge
stellungnahme wir können bestätigen dass
heute drei weitere deutsche kinder die
sich in nordsyrien in gewahrsam befunden
haben von dort aus gemeinsam mit ihrer
mutter in den irak ausreisen konnten nur
nach sorgfältiger einzelprüfung so heißt
es bei den sicherheitsbehörden ist die
ausreise von laura h nach deutschland
möglich geworden dutzende weitere fälle
müssten noch entschieden werden
jeder fall
in dem eine gefährliche person nicht
nach deutschland kommt ist ein guter
fall
ich möchte nicht dass gefährliche
personen nach deutschland kommen
gs kämpfer mit deutschem pass werden
weiter nicht konsularisch betreut nur
für kinder gab es bisher wege zurück nun
werden die mütter folgen denn die justiz
zwingt die bundesregierung dazu jetzt
liegen über mehrere gerichtsbeschlüsse
vor die ganz klar sagen es reicht nicht
nur kinder zurückzuholen sondern auch
die mütter müssen zurückgeführt werden
und nun reagiert deutschland und holt
erstmals eine sängerin aktiv zurück
laura h wird am abend auf dem flughafen
frankfurt eintreffen dann verhör durch
die bundespolizei einer der vorwürfe
mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen
vereinigung noch gibt es keinen
haftbefehl
angriffe und drohungen gegen
journalisten haben massiv zugenommen in
der letzten zeit auch in deutschland
die rechtsextreme npd hat heute drei
namentlich genannte kollegen unter
anderem vom ndr speziell ins visier
genommen und sie und gegen sie zu einer
demonstration aufgerufen
das wollen sich tausende nicht gefallen
lassen und deshalb gibt es aus hannover
heute vor allem ein signal für die
pressefreiheit
elisabeth schmidt und peter kunz
berichten die npd greift an gerangel
zwischen rechtsextremen und journalisten
in hannover
dabei sucht die nationaldemokratische
partei doch aufmerksamkeit ihr feindbild
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk und
die npd attackiert gezielt und
namentlich journalisten die kritisch
über die rechte szene berichten
das hat schon eine neue qualität und es
erinnert mich so ein bisschen an den
mittelalterlichen pranger wo auch jeder
noch mal drauf hauen konnte der deutsche
journalisten verband nennt es
einschüchterungstaktik die polizei
wollte den aufmarsch verbieten aber zwei
gerichte erlaubten die ihn im sinne der
versammlungs- und meinungsfreiheit
so legte die npd hannovers innenstadt
heute lahm und gut 7000 gegner der
rechtsextremen protestieren gegen die
partei die sich über so viel
öffentlichkeit dann auch freuen
wir sehen ja wie viele kameras haben wir
haben alleine 15 auf einem haufen auf
anderen straßenseite waren bestimmt
nochmal 30 120 npd-anhänger die gegen
journalisten zu felde ziehen ihre
ansichten geschützten mit viel aufwand
vom rechtsstaat in dem jeder seine
meinung haben darf kommunalpolitiker
verabschieden von ihren mandaten weil
wir angst haben wenn sogar listen
aufhören so recherchieren und zu
schreiben weil sie angst haben wenn das
passiert dann stirbt die demokratie von
unten so weit ist es noch nicht dafür
und für die pressefreiheit gegen
hannover heute auf die straße
drohen und beleidigen wie rechtsextreme
versuchen einzuschüchtern unsere online
kollegen haben mit einem betroffenen
journalisten gesprochen nachzulesen ist
das gespräch auf heute.de
bundesaußenminister heiko maas hat bei
seinem türkischen amtskollegen gegen die
verhaftung eines anwalts der deutschen
botschaft protestiert der jurist
überprüfte in deutschland auftrag die
angaben von asylbewerbern
er soll bei seiner festnahme sensible
daten türkischer staatsbürger bei sich
gehabt haben
maas sprach mit dem türkischen
außenminister mehr wirtschaftsschule am
rande des g20-gipfels in japan
er sagte dass die verhaftung des anwalts
das angespannte verhältnis zwischen
berlin und ankara
zusätzlich belaste habe ihm noch einmal
gesagt dass wir eigentlich kein
verständnis dafür haben und es ist noch
einmal gesagt worden dass der fall nun
von der türkischen justiz geprüft wird
letztlich ist das ein fall der
bedauerlicherweise wie viel zu viele
andere fälle in der türkei für uns nicht
nachvollziehbar ist deshalb werden wir
mit den verantwortlichen in der türkei
dazu auch im gespräch bleiben sagt der
bundesaußenminister
die proteste in lateinamerika greifen um
sich auch in kolumbien gehen sie auf die
straße gegen korruption gewalt
ungleichheit und umstrittene reformen
es sind hunderttausende kolumbianer und
manche demonstriere mit gewalt jetzt hat
die stadtverwaltung der hauptstadt
bogotá auf ausschreitungen reagiert mit
einer ausgangssperre bis auf wenige
ausnahmen darf in der nacht niemand mehr
sein haus verlassen
zuvor waren die proteste zu
straßenschlachten eskaliert drei
menschen starben mehr als 250 polizisten
und demonstranten wurden verletzt
proteste und straßenschlachten haben in
den letzten monaten auch hongkong
erschüttert demokratiebewegung gegen
peking treue regierung morgen nun werden
den hongkong bei der kommunalwahl die 18
bezirksräte gewählt normalerweise keine
große schlagzeile aber diesmal ist das
anders denn die kommunalwahlen sind die
einzigen in hongkong die demokratisch
genannt werden können und so hofft die
opposition auf ein starkes zeichen der
wähler ulf röller hongkong die stadt die
so viele tage und nächte der gewalt
erlebt hat lässt die spuren der
straßenschlachten verschwinden
ein hauch von normalität an einem ort an
dem an vielen ecken die polizei steht
hongkongs bürger zeigen ihren widerstand
gegen die machthaber in peking manchmal
nicht gleich sichtbar
das ist eine typische situation in
hongkong auf der einen seite haben wir
ein restaurant dass es pro peking und
das ist ziemlich leer
und auf der anderen seite haben da ein
restaurant das ist für die demonstranten
und dort stehen sie an und so stimmen
hongkongs bürger täglich mit den füßen
ab in der polytechnischen universität
haben sich immer noch studentin
verschanzt wer rauskommt wird von der
polizei sofort festgenommen
die 21 jährige tina hat das erfahren
ihr drohen zehn jahre gefängnis wegen
aufruhrs aber sie wird weiter
demonstrieren
wenn ich meine freunde sehe wie sie
kämpfen dann kann ich nicht einfach zu
hause bleiben und zu schauen
ich muss ihnen helfen und bei ihnen sein
am sonntag finden bezirks walenstadt
eine chance für hongkongs bürger ihren
protest auszudrücken an den
machtverhältnissen ändert sich zwar
nichts aber den peking treuen kandidaten
drohen verluste wegen der aufgeheizten
atmosphäre haben es politiker schwer die
für die hongkonger regierung sind
hongkong haben die monatelangen proteste
verändert in einer zerrissenen stadt
versuchen die bürger die hoffnung nicht
zu verlieren und zurück nach deutschland
wie wollen wir miteinander leben
30 jahre nach dem fall der mauer suchen
menschen im westen und osten
deutschlands antworten auf diese frage
ein ganz besonderer dialog der bürger
bringt sie im jubiläumsjahr zusammen 32
städte 16 treffen ein gemeinsames ziel
den anfang machen ludwigshafen in
rheinland pfalz und dessau-roßlau in
sachsen-anhalt die menschen in den
partnerstädten trennen 500 kilometer und
ihre erfahrungen auf der einen und der
anderen seite der innerdeutschen grenze
zwei blickwinkel auf die zukunft in
einem land lara hoffmann berichtet
stefanie siegel ist eine der wenigen
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer die den
mauerfall selbst nicht erlebt haben nach
dessau ist die gereist um zu erfahren ob
für die menschen hier ost und west
überhaupt noch eine rolle spielt es gibt
noch dieses ost und west denken hier
also das merkt man schon sehr stark und
das finde ich ein bisschen schade noch
weil es soll halt auch anders sein
insgesamt 85 bürgerinnen und bürger sind
gekommen um sich kennenzulernen
ein stückchen mehr zusammen zu wachsen
das möchte auch ein silber seit knapp 40
jahren lebt sie in ludwigshafen in
ostdeutschland war sie vorher noch nie
ich möchte das ist akzeptiert werden
ja ohne meine hautfarbe oder religion
zugehörigkeit gleichberechtigung was
auch klar wird es sind die gleichen
alltagssorgen ost wie west die die
menschen beschäftigen
und doch gibt es unterschiede ein wunsch
an die politik dort immer wieder auf
angleichung dass sie mit ihren
möglichkeiten etwas tut das zu verändern
solche großen ungleichgewichte zwischen
den millionenstädten und der region
rings herum zu beseitigen
analysten werten alle gespräche der
insgesamt 16 treffen aus mit den
ergebnissen möchte die bundesregierung
die kommunikation zwischen ost und west
zwischen bürgerinnen und bürgern
verbessern daran glauben nicht alle
ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwie
maßgebenden einfluss hat das glaube ich
nicht ob ich auch nicht
die gegebenheiten führungsebene sind
sich da ganz anders also da lässt man
sich sicher nicht durch diskussionen von
büren wie hier muss beim schießen war
vor allem eine sache wird heute klar
deutsche einheit ist ein prozess für den
es sich lohnt im austausch zu bleiben
schon seit zwei wochen kämpfen die
menschen im mittelmeerraum mit einem
unwetter nach dem anderen in der region
genua nordwesten von italien gilt jetzt
alarmstufe rot heftige regenfälle
erdrutsche überschwemmungen
ähnliche bilder aus dem südosten von
frankreich an der côte d'azur mussten
hunderte menschen vorsorglich ihre
häuser verlassen
ein mann wird vermisst es wird bei uns
in deutschland gleich erst hat man den
sport am samstag noch und wir schauen
erst auf die fußball bundesliga
die ist ja weiterhin super spannend denn
der aufsteiger aus berlin
der schlägt den tabellenführer aus
gladbach die bisherigen ergebnisse des
zwölften spieltages union berlin gewinnt
gegen gladbach mit 20 düsseldorf
unterliegt den bayern klar mit 0 4
leverkusen und freiburg 1 2 1 frankfurt
verliert gegen wolfsburg mit 0 2 bremen
unterliegt schalke mit 1 2 das
abendspiel leipzig gegen köln und
bereits gestern abend trennten sich
dortmund und paderborn 3 zu 3 ein blick
auf die tabelle
gladbach trotz der niederlage weiterhin
spitzenreiter aber nur noch mit einem
punkt vorsprung die bayern jetzt zweiter
mit 24 punkten freiburg dritter
punktgleich mit schalke auf platz vier
leipzig fünfter kann aber heute abend
wieder platz zwei zurück erobern
dortmund sechster und die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit frankfurt im
keller bislang alles unverändert mainz
auf platz 16 vor köln und schlusslicht
paderborn und das abendspiel leipzig
gegen köln das können sie dann bei uns
sehen aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr zu
gast frankfurt sportvorstand fredi bobic
doppelter doppelsitzer erfolg für die
deutschen rennrodler toni eggert und
sascha benecken siegten beim weltcup
auftakt in innsbruck vor den
olympiasiegern tobias wendt und tobias
arlt eine ganz ganz knappe entscheidung
im zweiten lauf
ganze neun tausendstel sekunden beträgt
am ende der vorstellung von toni eggert
und sascha benecken
die weltmeister verbessern sich im
zweiten lauf ohne erkennbare größere
fehler und mit bestzeit von platz vier
auf eins
die nachfolgenden tobias wendl und
tobias arlt liegen zwar bei allen
zwischenzeiten vorne im ziel ist aber
klar es ist eine hauptbühne team interne
niederlage
die dominanz der deutschen doppelsitzer
scheint aber ungebrochen
bei den damen überrascht
nachwuchsfahrerin jessica titel mit
platz drei den sie sich beim sieg der
russin tatjana iwanowa mit der
zeitgleichen teamkollegin julia taubitz
teilt die deutschen skispringer dagegen
haben zum weltcup-auftakt eine erste
podestplatzierung im teamwettbewerb klar
verpasst im polnischen wisla kam das
dsv-quartett richard freitag markus
eisenbichler stephan leyhe und karl
geiger bei schwierigen windbedingungen
nicht über den fünften platz hinaus
diese tiere her in vom team österreich
hatten heute ein grund zum jubeln die
deutsche mannschaft hingegen spielte bei
der entscheidung im ersten team
wettbewerb keine rolle
noch fehlte den weltmeistern das sprung
gefühl technische fehler bremsten
richard freitag markus eisenbichler
stephan leyhe und schlussspringer geiger
doch auch fehlende windunterstützung
machte dem dsv quartett zu schaffen
bei der premiere von stefan horngacher
als bundestrainer
die österreicher um top springer stefan
kraft deklassierten in whistler ihre
konkurrenten mit über 20 punkten
vorsprung siegten sie vor norwegen und
gastgeber polen und morgen gibt es
wieder wintersport skispringen rodeln
ski alpin eisschnelllauf und das alles
ab 10 uhr 13 dann bleib bei uns im zdf
10 13 10 34 stellen uns den weg jawohl
vielen dank ruhiges herbstwetter gibt's
morgen wo die sonne scheint gleich bei
aston terry 22 45 da freut sich der
kollege claus kleber auf sie im heute
journal und morgen sind wir wieder für
sie da sonntag 19 uhr bis dann machen
sie sich einen angenehmen abend
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter auf der
alpensüdseite dreht sich noch ein tief
und das bringt hier noch kräftigen regen
und schnee vor allem auf der
alpensüdseite richtung tessin sind gut
100 liter noch bis morgen möglich in
deutschland da ist es relativ ruhig mit
hohem luftdruck und so gibt es in der
nacht nebel richtung osten und auch im
westen im nordwesten sind viele wolken
unterwegs aber insgesamt bleibt es
trocken bei temperaturen von minus 1
grad in der eifel und 6 grad in
schleswig-holstein morgen im
tagesverlauf löst sich der nebel
allmählich auf und dann kommt die sonne
hervor
im westen kommt die sonne häufiger raus
oder auch im süden ab und zu auch mal
ganz im nordosten richtung oder richtung
ems da ist es dichter bewölkt bei
temperaturen von 14 grad an den alpen
hier wird es richtig mit kühler ist es
richtung nordosten und vor allem an der
ostsee mit 6 grad
die nächsten tage am montag ist es noch
relativ ruhig und trocken bei 5 bis 10
grad am dienstag kommt im westen regen
auf und mittwoch da deutet sich eine
weitere wetteränderungen an und es wird
deutlich nasa damit wünsche ich ihnen
einen schönen abend